Welcome back everyone it's charlie to be my
new shang chi trailer video marvel released
a whole bunch of new footage obviously this
is all focusing on hyping him up with the
avengers implying that he will eventually
crossover with the avengers eventually kind
of winking at that behind the camera.
The director was also talking about the post
credit scene.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos I will
be doing a whole bunch of videos for the movie
after he comes out and I do get a chance to
see it early with the critics screenings this
week then I'll post a review video is soon
as Marvel allows us to do that.
But as of me posting this video I have not
seen it yet.
In case you forgot the movies after coming
out in a couple weeks.
Hopefully theaters are open where you live
around the world.
But it is avengers trailer they hype up all
that Marvel phase one footage in her cutting
with Iron Man, Captain America in Thor's hammer
with the footage of shang chi's father the
mandarins showing him the 10 rings like opening
that case literally showing him the rings,
there's a conversation that they have in the
other trailer footage were he says, the rings
are calling to you now is one of the big reasons
why he wants him to come back after his big
rum spring up for the past 10 years and take
up the Corto quote family business that while
they're playing all that avengers footage
with his footage Michelle Yeoh's character
says you're a product of all who came before
you civil wasn't clear from all the trailer footage
Another was some confusion about the timeline.
The director actually literally just confirm
my theory that the movie was set in present
day after avengers endgame.
I did a video little while ago explaining
the whole timeline of marvel phase 4 with
the Disney plus series are happening right
now they're using the avengers infinity saga
movies in the original avengers characters.
To say that in the real world this new shang
chi movie is also a product of all the stuff
that Marvel has been doing since that first
iron man movie metaphorically and literally
because of all the 10 rings Mandarin Easter
eggs in the first Iron Man movie.
It was another trailer they released earlier
were Kevin Feige was talking about the connection
to the real Mandarin of the MCU and what was
happening during the first Iron Man film think
that was the real Mandarin who was working
through this cell that attacked Tony Stark's
convoy to steal their weapons, but using all
his avengers footage in the way they talk about it
It's also a clever way that marvel is saying
that shang chi will join the avengers in Avengers
5 when they make that movie in a couple years
to be a little while before we see Avengers
5 in the separate clip at the end of that
footage.
They also have the joke about the dance off
battle to save the universe from guardians
of the galaxy.
When he's talking about all the characters
that he wants shang chi to crossover with
in future marvel movies.
I'm surprised he says get a slice of pizza
with Iron Man and they didn't go for the swarm
a namedrop just because I feel like the obvious
go to if you're making a bunch of classic avengers references
But he namedrop's Iron Man twice and I understand
that this is meant to be a promo to get people
hyped up to buy tickets to the movies they
wanted to be very positive and happy one a
huge record drop jokes.
But Akwafina should have been.
Like well know you can't get pizza with Iron
Man because he's dead. He Died.
This is one of those conversations that you
have what you're waiting in line to comic
con for Hall age talking about the multiverse.
Well you know technically he could get pizza
with the multiverse version of Iron Man, but
my only big criticism of a lot of the promos
that they release for movies like this is
they tend to get kind of bland with the references
they make.
Like they don't want to be too confusing.
Like maybe some people haven't watch Loki
they don't understand how variance works.
He couldn't say I'd love to get a slice of
pizza with an iron man variant Tony Stark variant
But bringing background of the actual 10 rings
of power in the context of the shang chi movie
story Michelle yells characters after having
this conversation with him when she's training
him saying that he's both a product of his
mother who they're implying was a really good
person, it is also a product of his father
the Mandarin is a huge marvel villain was
her having the Darth Vader conversation with
them.
Like yes Luke Skywalker in the MCU.
Your mother was pad may she was a very good
person in your father is Darth Vader you're
going to have to reckon with that.
But being the son of one of the biggest villains
in the MCU doesn't have to dictate your destiny,
or define who you are is very broad.
Joseph Campbell heroes journey type of storytelling
that you see and a lot of these big comic book movies
They did the exact same thing with Peter Quill
and the guardians of the galaxy movies his
father one of the biggest cosmic marvel villains
metaphorically and literally because he is
the size of a planet later during the trailer
footage you see him taking the 10 rings of
power from the Mandarin as they bond with
his arms their energy changes from the blue
energy that the Mandarin was giving off to
the gold energy the you see given off by the
dragons flying around this ancient village
because the way they explained a lot of these
bigger cosmic characters powers in the MCU.
I'm just wondering if his mother is supposed
to be part Dragon or this is him wielding
the same kind cosmic energy that his mother's
people these monks use because it looks very
similar to the energy of these staffs in this
giant door in the background here also kind
of wondering if his mother came from this
group of monks this protecting this special
door here with the great protector Dragon
whose name basically says that all their here
to protect something they've changed a lot
about the mandarins back story in the back
story the 10 rings of power in the MCU.
But the movies coming out in a couple weeks.
So thankfully we won't have to wait that long
to get all the answers but really easy prediction
to make for the next big avengers movie.
Because shang chi is supposed to be in that
next big avengers film all the scenes of him
wielding the power of the rings with his gold
energy that is giving up is exactly what is
going to look like in that next avengers movie
when is crossing over with all these the characters
their having some big fight the other big
question now to I'm also wondering if his
power arc in the MCU's can be similar to Thor's
power arc, because the way they played him
over his trilogy movies.
I'm getting for Thor films is going to be
a little bit different.
But in the first two Thor movies.
He got better and better with the Hammer more
creative use of hammer then we get to Thor
Ragnarok they take the hammer away in eventually
Thor learned that it was never about the hammer
he's not the god of hammers.
So maybe in the MCU shang chi will have a
similar arc with Thor in his sequels.
The whole thing with this longer fight scene
that they put in here, the scaffolding fight
scene is just meant to showcase the martial
arts action scenes throughout the movie.
This is marvel's first big kung fu action
film the whole idea the character is that
originally when Marvel introduced them in
the comics, he was meant to be they are version
of Bruce Lee.
Just because he was introduced during the
big 1970s kung fu craze and pop-culture this
is kind of like marvel trying to do a Bruce
Lee kung fu action movie marvel's enter the
Dragon only in this movie.
They have an actual Dragon even happier tournament
arc like you had in the enter the Dragon movie.
I believe between all the different trailer
footage we see in the past month we've seen
small pieces of all the biggest fight scenes
in the movie, but in terms of post credit
scenes mid credit scenes as I said the director
did say that definitely states in the credits,
because there's some really important post
credit scenes I think because he's a brand-new
character in the MCU.
They also want to have some really big
post credit scene.
But remember the mid credit scenes that Marvel
does usually are just funny moments to pay
off something that happened earlier in the
movie in a funny way.
Like with the characters may be a scene paying
off the joke about Wong getting his ass kicked
by the abomination all the really big stuff
that they do usually happens in the actual
post credit scenes.
That's the one that they use to push story
forward and tease the next big movie or some
movie this coming down the road to easy pics
right now are like a scene with Val and the
abomination setting up more thunderbolts her
dark avengers connecting things more to thunderbolt
Ross or a bigger doctor strange 2 scene with
long connecting to that movie.
The next movie.
Right after shang chi is the Eternals movie.
But the thing is is this not a really huge
connection between the Eternals characters
in the shang chi characters other than to
say the Mandarin character in the Eternals
characters are all extremely long-lived so
the Eternals would probably know about the
10 rings of power.
He does live in San Francisco.
So the next best option could also be a multiverse
teaser through Kang the conqueror in Ant-Man 3
That's a bit of a stretch so post all you
theories in the comments below what you think
the shang chi post credit scenes are going
to be like I said if I do get a chance to
see the movie early this week will post my
review as soon as Marvel lets us do that my
full marvel what if episode 2 video will post
on Wednesday.
That's the Black Panther T'challa Star Lord
episode.
So make sure you have alerts enabled so you
don't miss that.
Because it is going to be a banger they just
did a big Spider-Man no way home first look
video for that new scene from the movie that
we got a look at in some new promos they released.
So click here for that and click here for
that what if episode 2 trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you the next video!